president Trump watched the first half
of last night's game at his Golf Club in
West Palm Beach Florida before flying
back to Washington on Air Force One
he told Face the Nation moderator
Margaret Brennan that he wouldn't want
to see his 12 year old son on the
gridiron would you let your son Barron
play football it's very it's a very
tough question it's a very good question
if he wanted to yes would I steer him
that way no I wouldn't why I wouldn't
and he actually plays a lot of soccer
he's liking soccer and a lot of people
including me thought soccer would
probably never make it in this country
but it really is moving forward rapidly
I just don't like the reports that I see
coming out having to do with football
concussions
yeah concussions and other things knees
and hips and shoulders and elbows and
everything else I mean it's a dangerous
sport and I think it's you know it's
really tough
I thought the equipment would get better
and it has the helmets have gotten far
better but it hasn't solved the problem
now that unusually personal reflection
came in an exclusive interview that
aired on Face the Nation yesterday this
morning we have some remarks you haven't
seen yet Margaret asked the president
about a potential threat from the
Democratic controlled House of
Representatives are you prepared for an
attempt to impeach you the only way they
can win because they can't win the
election is to bring out the artificial
way of impeachment and the problem is
you can't impeach somebody for doing the
best job of any president and the
history of our country for the first two
years and people have seen and people
have watched what we've done whether
it's tax cuts no political but you know
it's supposed to be high crimes and
misdemeanors well there was no high
crime
there was no misdemeanor there was no
problem whatsoever the only thing I've
done is created maybe the best economy
we've had in the history of our country
and the only way they can win I look at
these folks with the horrible situation
right now on abortion where they're
saying late term they're not even
talking about late term they're talking
about the baby is born and they can kill
this child this innocent child what
they're doing on abortion what they're
doing on high taxes what they're doing
at the border what they're doing
in so many different ways who they want
to cut our military they want to take
our wealth and give it away they want to
tax people not 70 percent it's a hundred
percent because what they want to do
you'd have to quadruple taxes you
wouldn't have enough money anywhere and
throughout the whole world you wouldn't
have enough money so if you look at what
they're running on they can't win so the
only way they could possibly beat me
because they're not going to win the
election I understand that they
understand they cannot win the election
the president also gave a surprising
reason for wanting to keep US troops in
Iraq well we spent a fortune on building
this incredible base we might as well
keep it and one of the reasons I want to
keep it is because I want to be looking
a little bit at Iran because Iran is a
real problem
whoa that's news you're keeping troops
in Iraq because you want to be able to
strike in Iran no because I want to be
able to watch your an all I want to do
is be able to watch we have an
unbelievable and expensive military base
built in Iraq it's perfectly situated
for looking at all over different parts
of the troubled Middle East rather than
pulling up and this is what a lot of
people don't understand we're going to
keep watching Face the Nation moderator
in senior foreign affairs correspondent
Margaret Brennan is in Atlanta where
Face the Nation originated from
yesterday Margaret good morning good
morning to you quite a long wide-ranging
great interview let me ask you about the
the way that answer on Iraq and Iran
resonated in the region well it did not
go over well
Iraq's President had to respond today
and said don't overburden us with your
issues here's what the president did
that made it very difficult for our
allies to do what we're asking them to
remember for US troops to stay in Iraq
we need Baghdad's
mission the 5,000 troops who are already
there are at the request of Iraq's
leadership to fight Isis but Trump says
President Trump says that fight has
already been won now he says he wants to
keep troops there in order to watch Iran
and that sounds a whole lot like a
threat against a country with a lot of
influence in Iraq so the president with
these comments may have endangered
delicate diplomatic talks that were
underway and made it more politically
difficult for Iraq to do what America
wants it to do Margaret you also asked
the president about his his read on what
his intelligence chiefs had said about
Iran what did he say about what the
nature of the disagreement was well the
president said he a hundred percent
disagrees if his intelligence chiefs
tell him Iran is a wonderful
kindergarten that was a quote of course
that's not what they're telling him in
fact the CIA director said no Iran is
abiding by the terms of the nuclear deal
they're not building a nuclear weapon
right now but those facts as the
intelligence community presents them are
based on surveillance and they have not
persuaded the president also interesting
to hear the president say he will not
withdraw troops from the Korean
Peninsula a lot of news made yes during
a great interview Margaret thank you